there was one thing from the Jordan dock
that I forgot to mention so before our
right at the start of each episode
he dropped a sneaker what you mean like
Jordan dropped a sneaker at the start of
each episode I read fives during the
first episode what was the second
episode the the black and gold sevens I
believe cool I didn't miss I missed out
on the 5-7 them I'm caught
okay besides but even that that market
is so [ __ ] genius I don't know who's
him and who just I don't know who's
nuggins I got the alert on my phone I
didn't like Forrest because right away
right and imagine you're like oh i'm so
hype on jordan right now like so many
people probably just impulse bought
those [ __ ] twins aback yo big good man
good yo it is gonna get a surge man
Jordan Brand is gonna get a huge surge
I'm hyped to buy Jordans again I was
done by his sneakers I'm 36 so I'm done
I was off Jordans - I was like too many
people got on there's too many colorways
blah blah blah but you really see the
reason why we purchased things its
identity man yeah we are and somebody
said this is how I want to take credit
for this but this is how Jordan changed
the sneaker game because it was the
first time the sneakers were truly
marketed aspirationally be like Mike
it's got to be the shoes it's rain yeah
yeah be like Mike it's got to be the
shoes you can be like this person yeah
because he was someone you admired so
much and that's why we've been talking
about this podcast a lot when we talk
about selecting a sneaker for a type of
player you you have to choose a style of
play that's aspirational that's why I
would never give big men most big men
traditional big men a sneaker cuz nobody
wants to be a plotting back you in bully
you and then have a [ __ ] shooter some
sort of like contested layup nobody
wants that we want Allen Iverson I don't
I resent it some the most ugly sneakers
ever made but he was so incredible you
aspired to be him so much that you
but whatever is on his feet on yours
like if Zion goes full Shack mode full
Young Shack mode yeah that's a sneaker
you might want because he's bouncy
here's the thing it's like yo you could
be big and bouncy here's the thing and
this is the only reason why I give you a
little pushback
I think his physique is so rare that we
don't relate to it where is Vince Carter
who had a much more relatable physique
mm-hmm I bought the [ __ ] bounce
sneakers resumes and these are bub hits
do you know a country living in the most
obese [ __ ] country every big person
will think oh I can bounce like Zion I
see Zion as like massive muscles I don't
see him as just like a thick yes the
same way how girls who are fat call
themselves thick right I heard you
saying but that's what that's I like Tim
Duncan I would never now sneaker deal
nobody's buying senior to play like Tim
Duncan they want to play like Mike man I
also think there's an excitement to more
high-flying [ __ ] like the last big man
who's exciting kind of Dwight Howard in
the dunk contest on to compose Jonas is
less being less excited yeah yeah I and
I guess to your point you don't really
care for his sneakers I think that he
has the type of game where you could be
into it because he kind of plays like a
guard he's dunking and he's like long
but like the average big man like I
don't want a [ __ ] I was gonna say
Shaq wasn't he was exciting for like a
split second one eatin but like Zion is
taking off sure yes
is a great example yeah would you wear
an Anthony Davis sneakers he's not
exciting it's not like you have to be
outta my seat
it's like irregular like Steph's game
was I bought Stef sneakers because the
game was so irregular I think some part
of my brain was gone well maybe the
sneakers give you a little bit more
balance and then you can shoot a three
and ya better be zoom or my brain
couldn't put together why he was so
effective and why is this obviously
sometimes I may be and Georgia had it's
crazy the power of subconscious I did
not realize I wore Jordans yesterday
until I got to the studio and everybody
was wearing Georgia and then it way I
just hit me I was like I'm a [ __ ]
sheep that's what got me hoes like oh
I've that's it don't you wear the
kairi's because of that like you think
you can like change direction a little
walk I Reece I did my research on the
car he's 100% Chad
game is so abnormal he said finishes at
the rim so well right and he's so like
squirmy I was like what happens I did
research on his sneakers like we we
looked at a motorcycle tire and how
there's tread up on the side because
you're leaning and you want to be able
to have traction while you're leaning
and I started convincing myself like oh
my crossover I actually leave so I don't
want to slide out but it starts from
looking at this guy who has a game who
is so confusing your brain doesn't make
sense of it so you start believing that
the sneaker has something to do with it
it's no different than a conspiracy
theorist the world is so confusing to
you so you're like okay maybe it's flat
yeah you know or okay maybe the banks or
all this right it's the same thing it's
like a cognitive distance kicks in I
need to figure out what's really going
yeah I'm happy sent you know as an
offshoot of it I was also thinking how
sneaker culture is so big in New York
this is the only place that could have
popped off whereas in New York or a
walking City because people see you
wearing this [ __ ] I was thinking about
when I was in Texas when I grew up in
Texas I used to look at like nice cars
and gotta go out walk that because where
do I spend most of my time my car now I
don't give a [ __ ] about cars but I'm on
the street looking at people walking I
see nice sneakers over and over again I
see enough of those oh my god really
want those yeah man cars are sneakers
are cars yeah it's totally true it's a
way to like show wealth it's a way to
show status just like your cars your
show wealth and status it's something
you're extremely harshly judged by yeah
you got a shitty car and I imagine a
place like Texas or California
[ __ ] looking at you weird yeah
la la 100% you can't have a shitty car
in LA I remember you telling me you had
a Corolla rental and you were like man
if I move down here I could never have
this car so a Toyota Corolla when I went
to school in California I didn't even
care yeah people are looking at the car
and I was like who cares yeah I don't
understand yeah why would you spend
extra money on the car that's how I feel
about my brain I'm like while you spend
this with my little car like you can't
wear it all day yeah I can get a hundred
pair of sneakers for less than a car
yeah where's shifted up every day I'm
good yeah [ __ ] out here I'll go
to a mall just a [ __ ] see your
[ __ ] yeah if you're in LA or @x exactly
that's great that makes so much sense I
saw a video of these guys in Florida
trying to break into this house yeah and
then they got shot at yeah by the guy
who owned the house yeah but they were
in slides these [ __ ] didn't
even wear sneakers to break into a house
they were doing a Breaking and Entering
in slides you saw a video and I was like
wow you really don't care about sneakers
around here are we the only ones it's
got to be a city that cares about
athletics fashion black cultures got an
impact and then you walk it's growing in
Europe and the sneaker culture is blown
but also it's always been popping in
Europe you walked a lot in here even
when I was a kid though when I was like
young young I remember going Europe is
the illest the illest colorways they
weren't really a illest but they were
ones we didn't have so we really valued
valued them but they were always fly
with this interesting because when I
turn up on Jordans they never [ __ ] with
Jordan I was always like a running
sneaker or like a yeah at the height of
it at the height of the Jordan craze I
was in London and I was like I could get
every pair that I can't get in the US
right yeah yeah yeah Jordan is one
problem to them because they don't care
about basketball yeah the aspiration
[ __ ] wasn't there
Yeah right but now are you saying even
there it's getting popular yeah cuz I
saw this you know that don't rush
challenge [ __ ] yeah I saw like European
girls did it take on it with sneakers so
huh they was sure like their sneaker
collection and they had some joints in
there yeah and then after they do the
little little thing where they block the
screen and then they come back then they
like have a nice outfit with the sneaker
yeah none of them know how to dress
though right but they have flies new
yeah they could not put everywhere in
Europe your walk do you think Jordans
the first athlete to ever have like the
aspirational sneaker aspect like it like
before any other athlete it seems that
way before him like was there any other
basketball player that had like Chuck
Taylor whatever but like was there any
other athletes from my lifetime much I
think he was the first anybody might be
like Chuck Chuck first commercial of the
band Jordan was self [ __ ] brilliant
the NBA banned these sneakers we can't
show them to you and then it Scrolls
down I think they cut off before they
get to the sneaker but you'll watch the
game and see which sneakers are talking
about look up the band Jordan one
commercial the original commercial it's
[ __ ] brilliant orden came up with
that Brandon
be like Mike now it's good idea yeah
like that was the first time you saw it
like oh if you wear the sneaker you'd be
like the person oh yeah that was the
tagline it was like on oh yeah let's do
it
it was a Gatorade commercial wasn't even
shoes it was Gatorade like Mike if I
could be like Mike I'm pretty sure a
Gatorade there's a song yeah I could be
like
[Applause]